a story with a simple premise of a hero
that can defeat everything that stands
in his way with one punch might not seem
interesting
however this gem of a show has a way of
keeping you hooked dim even characters
that were briefly introduced are
interesting as they fight with ferocity
and power everyone's extremely strong
and capable of showcasing epic fight
moments as long as they don't face off
against the main character of course and
on that note today we're listening the
top 10 most powerful characters in one
punch man please note that while some of
the characters in the anime are stronger
than the ones on the list or for that
matter their position on the list it's
yet to be shown how strong their actual
abilities are so this list will focus on
actual fights
starting of our list at number 10 is
Sonic no no not that Sonic speed of
sound Sonic's one of the fastest
characters in one punch man he may seem
calm due to his intense training as a
ninja but deep underneath that facade is
a battle maniac he craves fighting
against those stronger than him and is
excited by the prospect of finding a
strong opponent which ends up being
Saitama he attacks with a sword and
performs quick slashes on his opponents
reminiscent of a samurais slash despite
his skills and battle prowess he's last
on this list which just goes to show how
strong the characters in the show are
running old-school
[Music]
[Music]
coming in at number nine is forty forty
prisoner he's the last rank in the
s-class and understandably he's quite
the eccentric one to have in this list
however his strength the real deal he's
ripped with muscles from top to bottom
and it's like a tank in human form as he
walks into battle with nothing but his
raw strength and muscles he has a
special mode court angel style that
pushes his strengths to its maximum
limits the unfortunate side effect of
this though at least for observers of
the fight is that his clothes get ripped
off completely because this rapid
increased muscle mass however in this
mode he's many times stronger and is
able to pack quite some damage as seen
in the fight against the deep sea king
number eight on our list is metal bat
metal bats an s-rank hero who's
reminiscent of the old delinquent
protagonists from earlier anime series
that rely on fighting spirit and guts to
fight that's not to say that he doesn't
have any fighting skills though he's
really good in a fight and has the
ability to spot the weaknesses of his
enemies like in the recent clash against
elder centipede his fighting spirit
allows him to become increasingly
stronger not only in terms of power but
agility and speed as well in proportion
to the damage he accumulates in this
regard he's durable and can keep
fighting on he was almost able to take
out Goro
despite the continuous fights and damage
he accumulated and the only thing that
stopped him was his little sister yes
that's right the delinquent heroes
biggest weakness is his sister whom he
dotes upon
studies and Keanu high cuz it
[Music]
coming in at number seven is Janice
Janice is by and large a fan favorite of
the series he comes with a tragic past
where his whole town and family were
killed and destroyed he became a cyborg
with the help of a professor solely in
pursuit of revenge due to which he has
inch humane strength and speed his
destructive capabilities are quite
impressive as well as his large area of
effect attacks even amongst the s-class
he constantly strives to be stronger and
better than he was before this
seriousness actually pairs off really
well with a laid-back attitude of his
master and is quite endearing to watch
[Music]
[Music]
number six on our list is the deep sea
king the first major villain to appear
in the series of course has to have a
mention in this list when this monster
appeared he really did put up a huge
fight against our heroes when we first
introduced to him it's in his shriveled
state however he was able to take on 40
40 prisoner in that stay and wounded a
number of heroes in his wet state form
his strength is phenomenal to say the
least
he really bashes in GNO stirring this
form he was able to wreak a crazy amount
of damage and inspire real fear into the
citizens regardless of his anti-climatic
defense
coming in at number 5 on the list is
atomic samurai the fourth-ranked s-class
hero atomic samurais quite a proud
person even though he seems to give off
a laid-back personality he's a
formidable individual who uses a katana
and true to his name is able to take
care of all of his opponents in a single
instant with his signature atomic slash
move he was able to cut a monster to
bits using a mere toothpick he has his
own school of teaching with disciples
who are all in the top of the a rank
next comes bank or better known by his
hero named silver Fang number 3s ranked
heroes silver Fang is one of the most
accomplished martial artists alive he's
one of the oldest characters in the show
but don't get deceived by his frail old
appearances he's quite true to his hero
named silver Fang in the way that he
completely decimates his opponents he
uses a form of martial art known as
water stream rocks smashing fists with
this martial art and backed with body
packing immense strength this old man's
quite a serious threat to handle he's
one of the hero association's toughest
close-range fighters and one of the few
who actually acknowledges saitama's true
strength asserted my audience Commodore
[Music]
[Applause]
coming in at number three on our list is
Tatsu machi the tornado of terror yes
this list wouldn't be complete without
the sassy lolly as Saitama first calls
her she's an esper the strongest in the
world in fact and like other psychics
shown so far in the show she doesn't
simply lift spoons or small objects
she's able to literally pick up sections
of a city and then just fling it at her
opponents the trail of destruction she
leaves behind is what's given her the
name tornado of terror she's ranked 2 in
the s-class so despite her childish look
she's supposedly 28 years old she
considers destroying monsters her duty
even doing so in her free time just to
kill her boredom
[Music]
or it's kind of down
[Music]
number two on a list and by no mean feat
is Boris Boris is an alien being that
came to earth in the name of conquest
however we later find out that there was
another ulterior motive he's such a
powerful being that he's conquered
numerous planets and has reached an
existential crisis similar to what
Saitama is going through now he doesn't
find anything challenging anymore and
his board of his existence he later
hears of a prophecy of an individual who
exists on earth he'll be able to give
him the fight of the centuries he's
always wanted Boris was also the first
person that made Saitama actually use
his serious series and punch
withstanding a number of saitama's
normal punches which were able to
destroy everything else no other being
till date has been able to deal with it
anyway whatever she died updating the
die
finally after hours of deliberation and
round our list with the hero of the show
Cape Baldy or as he prefers it
Saitama now that wasn't really
surprising was it when it shouldn't be
because after all he's the hero that
literally defeats almost all of his
opponents with one punch
he's the satire of the story however
perhaps it's just his power of will he
has overwhelming power which he could
use to easily rule the world but he
quite simply chooses to live a normal
life he doesn't even care to be
recognized not bothering to take credit
for a number of monster kills that gave
King his place in the S ranks in a very
comic sense of course this attitude is
impressive and perhaps his biggest
strength along with his ability to end
everything with one punch
he conducted on
with this we come to the end of our top
10 but hold on a second we do have one
honorable mention in this list
Garo the new antagonist in the latest
season of the show
he's a form of a disciple of bank but
due to his fascination of monsters and
hatred of heroes he goes down the path
of becoming a self-declared monster he's
definitely able to put up a serious
fight injuring a number of a class
heroes in a few s-class heroes so far
showing his immense strength agility and
speed on top of being a trained martial
artist with numerous techniques a lot of
you must be wondering why he wasn't
mentioned in this list but till now it's
not really quite clear yet how far he'll
go from an anime only perspective will
be interesting to see how strong he gets
hope you enjoyed watching the videos so
far please do leave a like if you did
and subscribe to be updated when a new
video comes out I'll see you next time
on vinnie tube
[Music]
[Music]